rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler de Platon et de
l'Atlantide
l'Atlantide est un sujet extrêmement
polémique c'est un sujet qui alimente de
très nombreuses théories plus ou moins
réalistes plus ou moins crédible mais
c'est aussi un sujet qui alimente la
perplexité pour ne pas dire la moquerie
car pour les historiens l'Atlantide n'a
jamais existé
c'est une légende
au mieux un récit mythique
mais pas une réalité historique
alors que pour d'autres au contraire
l'Atlantide a réellement existé
ou en tout cas il reste ouvert à
l'hypothèse
et cette hypothèse elle a une origine
ses Platons
ces Platon qui le premier a émis l'idée
qu'il avait existé une île nommée
Atlantide qui avait hébergé une
civilisation ayant précédé la nôtre les
fameux Atlantes et que ces Atlantes
possédaient un niveau de connaissances
et de technologie supérieure
alors certes Platon n'était pas
historien mais ce n'était pas non plus
un poète
dans l'Antiquité ce qui écrivait les
mythes on les appelait les poètes
Homère Hésiode et chill
Platon n'était pas un poète c'était un
philosophe et quand il parle de
l'Atlantide il précise qu'il parle de
quelque chose de réel
autrement dit il ne présente pas le
récit de l'Atlantide comme un mythe
l'ennui c'est que ça va complètement à
contre sens de la version officielle de
l'histoire
selon l'histoire officielle aucune
civilisation ne nous a précédé
du simple fait qu'on en a trouvé aucune
trace
c'est encore on avait des traces on
pourrait envisager qu'une autre
civilisation est existé avant nous
mais là on a rien
ce on a rien certains le contestent
il le conteste au motif qu'il existerait
à la surface de la Terre un certain
nombre de vestiges voire un certain
nombre de monuments dont les hommes de
notre civilisation ne pourraient pas
être les bâtisseurs
parce qu'à l'époque où ils ont été
construits on ne possédait pas les
compétences techniques et industrielles
pour édifier de tels monuments
on pense par exemple aux pyramides de
Gizeh
des sites auréolées de mystères
et donc pour certains ces monuments
seraient l'oeuvre des Atlantes
une civilisation technologiquement
avancée qui aurait disparu dans un
gigantesque cataclysme
un déluge
une civilisation qui aurait possédé un
degré de sagesse et de connaissance bien
supérieur aux autres mais qui au fil du
temps serait devenu corrompu
au point que Dieu lui-même l'aurait fait
disparaître dans les eaux
et bien tout ça ça vient de Platon
alors cette chaîne n'est pas une chaîne
d'histoire ni d'archéologie donc on ne
va pas se prononcer sur la réalité
historique de l'Atlantide
on va plutôt se demander qu'est-ce que
le récit de l'Atlantide peut nous
apporter philosophiquement
parce que que l'Atlantide soit une
réalité ou pas il n'empêche que la
description qu'on fait Platon nous
pousse à la réflexion
une réflexion sur ce que nous sommes et
une réflexion sur la nature de l'univers
donc qu'est-ce que l'Atlantide peut nous
apprendre sur le monde et sur nous-mêmes
et bien c'est ce qu'on va tenter de
découvrir aujourd'hui
Platon nous parle de l'Atlantide dans
deux textes dans le chrétien et dans le
timet
chrétien se rapporte le témoignage d'un
ami de son grand-père un certain Saulon
l'un des 7 sages de la Grèce et qui lors
d'une visite en Egypte aurait été
informé par des prêtres de l'existence
d'une ancienne civilisation nommée
l'Atlantide
c'est prêtre lui ont expliqué que 9000
ans plus tôt il y a une guerre entre
Athènes et l'Atlantide
alors 9000 ans plus tôt on comprend pas
parce que 9000 ans plus tôt Athènes
n'était pas censé exister
bien justement les prêtres égyptiens ont
dit à son long que les Grecs existaient
depuis bien plus longtemps mais qu'ils
avaient oublié leur histoire
qu'ils avaient oublié leur passé
et l'un d'eux lui a même dit cette
phrase très énigmatique il lui a dit
vous autres Grecs vous êtes toujours des
enfants
alors selon de comprend pas il demande
au prêtre qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
et le prêtre lui répond
à intervalles réguliers les
civilisations sont détruites par de
grands cataclysmes soit par le feu soit
par l'eau
il y a 9000 ans
mais elle a disparu à cause d'un déluge
un déluge d'une telle puissance que le
continent Atlant a été englouti
et ce déluge n'est pas arrivé n'importe
quand il est arrivé juste après une
guerre entre l'armée atlante et l'armée
athénienne
son engloutissement a donc toutes les
apparences d'un châtiment
et c'est pas moi qui dit c'est le prêtre
égyptien
il nous dit les déluge sont des
purifications divines
on pense immédiatement aux déluge de la
Bible Dieu qui s'aperçoit que les êtres
humains qu'il a créé sont violents et
corrompus et qui décide d'exterminer sa
propre création
bien dans le cas des Atlantes il
semblerait que ce soit exactement la
même chose
les Atlantes étaient au départ une
civilisation vertueuse une civilisation
harmonieuse et au fil des générations
les Atlantes sont devenus des cadres
ils ont perdu leur vertu
ils ont été gagnés parce que les Grecs
appellent lubrisse
l'avidité
et cette avidité à causé leur perte
causant au passage l'extinction de la
civilisation grecque
alors il y aurait beaucoup de choses à
retenir de ce récit mais pour les
besoins de l'explication on va en
retenir trois
la première qui concerne davantage la
Grèce que l'Atlantide c'est la notion de
mémoire
le prêtre dit à son long les Grecs ont
perdu la mémoire
et parce qu'ils ont perdu la mémoire ils
ont dû tout réapprendre
une civilisation c'est un héritage
au plus précisément une civilisation
s'appuie constamment sur un héritage
un héritage historique un
héritage culturel un héritage
technologique
vous par exemple vous faites partie
d'une civilisation dont vous utilisez
les connaissances et les technologies
et bien entendu ces technologies n'ont
pu être développées que parce qu'elles
reposent sur des technologies
antérieures
par exemple l'informatique c'est une
technologie qui est issue à la fois des
mathématiques et de l'électronique
et avant l'électronique il y avait la
mécanique
par exemple la machine à calculer de
Pascal au 17e siècle
et avant les machines à calculer il y
avait les bouliers
on n'a pas inventé directement les
algorithmes informatiques
il y a eu des étapes
de longues étapes
pourquoi je dis tout ça
pour vous faire comprendre qu'une
civilisation repose entièrement sur
cette faculté qui est la mémoire
et que donc l'oubli est synonyme de
disparition d'une civilisation
si demain on nous réveillons nous étions
tous frappés d'amnésie notre
civilisation s'effondrerait
nous devrions tout réapprendre
la mémoire c'est ce qui fait qu'on n'a
pas besoin de tout réapprendre
il fait que nous pouvons partir de ce
que la civilisation nous a légué
c'est la célèbre phrase de Rabelais nous
sommes des nains sur des épaules de
géants
les géants c'est l'histoire qui nous a
précédé
et la mémoire de cette histoire
aujourd'hui nous délégons notre mémoire
à des ordinateurs
supposons qu'un cataclysme vient casser
l'ordinateur central ben on fera pas les
Fiero
parce qu'alors c'est le cœur
technologique de notre mémoire
civilisationnelle qui disparaît
il faudra tout recommencer
ce que dit le prêtre égyptien à son long
c'est que c'est exactement ce qui est
arrivé aux Athéniens
suite au déluge tout leur savoir ont
disparu
c'est pour ça que les Athéniens n'ont
pas la mémoire de leur guerre contre la
quantité
et c'est pour ça que le prêtre égyptien
dit que les Grecs sont toujours des
enfants
qu'il n'y a pas de vieillard en Grèce
le vieillard c'est celui qui possède la
mémoire la plus remplie
le disque dur le plus lourd
d'où le fait que la sagesse est
traditionnellement représentée par la
vieillesse
la vieillesse de celui qui a vécu et qui
a la mémoire de ce qu'il a vécu
et le prêtre ajoute que la différence
entre les Grecs et les Égyptiens c'est
que les égyptiens n'ont pas perdu la
mémoire
ils connaissent leur passé
alors pourquoi eux et pas les Grecs
parce que dit le prêtre l'Égypte a été
épargné par les cataclysmes
en raison de sa situation géographique
et plus particulièrement du Nil
voici ce qu'il dit je cite
il y a eu souvent il y aura encore
souvent des destructions d'hommes
causées de diverses manières les plus
grandes par le feu et par l’eau et
d'autres moindres parmi l'autre chose
les corps qui circulent dans le ciel
autour de la Terre dévie de leur course
et une grande conflagration qui se
produit à de grands intervalles détruit
ce qui est sur la surface de la Terre
alors tous ceux qui habitent dans les
montagnes et dans les endroits élevés et
arides périssent plutôt que ceux qui
habitent au bord des fleuves et de la
mer nous autres nous avons le Nil notre
Sauveur ordinaire qui en parika aussi
nous préserve de cette calamité par ses
débordements quand au contraire les
dieux submergent la terre sous les eaux
pour la purifier les habitants des
montagnes Bouvier et prêtres échappent à
la mort mais ceux qui réside dans vos
villes sont emportés par les fleuves
dans la mer tandis que chez nous ni dans
ce cas ni dans d'autres l'eau ne dévale
jamais des hauteurs dans les campagnes
c'est le contraire elle monte
naturellement toujours en bas voilà
comment et pour quelle raison on dit de
chez nous que ce sont conservés les
traditions les plus anciennes aussi tout
ce qui s'est fait de beau de grands ou
de remarquables sous tout autre rapport
soit chez vous soit ici soit dans tout
autre pays dont nous ayons entendu
parler tout cela se retrouve ici
consigné par écrit dans nos temples
depuis un temps immémorial et c'est
ainsi conservé chez vous au contraire et
chez les autres peuples à peine
êtes-vous pourvu de l’écriture et de
tout ce qui est nécessaire aux cité que
de nouveau après l'intervalle de temps
ordinaire des torandos du ciel fontent
sur vous comme une maladie et ne laisse
survivre de vous que les illettrés et
les ignorants en sorte que vous vous
retrouvez au point de départ comme des
jeunes ne sachant rien de ce qui s'est
passé dans les temps anciens soit ici
soit chez vous
donc vous comprenez maintenant je pense
en quoi la civilisation est
indissociable de la notion de mémoire
et donc en quoi l'oubli est synonyme de
disparition d'une civilisation
éventuellement de sa renaissance
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la
deuxième chose qu'il faut retenir du
récit de l'Atlantide qui est la
dégénérescence
la dégénérescence c'est le fait pour un
organisme ou pour une société
d'aller vers la dégradation
et il faut entendre dégradation au sens
littéral
le fait de perdre son grade de perdre
son rang
la dégénérescence c'est la décadence
et la cause de la dégénérescence selon
Platon c'est la corruption
la corruption inhérente à l'être humain
la corruption qui conduit l'être humain
sur une sorte de pente de la
vieillissement
j'ai déjà fait un épisode sur la
corruption chez Platon dans lequel on a
vu que la corruption n'était pas
seulement un phénomène moral mais
qu'elle était aussi une loi physique et
métaphysique
les êtres humains sont des êtres de
chair en tant qu'être de chair ils sont
soumis à des désirs des désirs sensuels
des désirs matériels et donc la
corruption c'est le propre des êtres
soumis à des désirs matériels
c'est ce qu'on retrouvera dans le
christianisme avec ce qu'on appelle le
péché de chair la tentation la tentation
symbolisée par Satan dont l'objectif est
de nous faire descendre dans la matière
si l'enfer est situé au centre de la
Terre c'est parce que c'est l'endroit le
plus bas
et c'est en même temps le plus dense le
plus compact
contraire du Paradis qui lui se situe
dans l'au-delà
là où la gravité n'existe plus
donc l'homme est un être de chair parce
qu'il est un être de chair il est soumis
à la tentation et quand sa vertu ça
faiblit autrement dit quand le
comportement des hommes commence à être
infiltré par des désirs autres que le
désir de vertu c'est l'engrenage de la
corruption
donc pour en revenir aux Atlantes
chrétiens nous dit que ce peuple a connu
une dégénérescence
qu'il s'est laissé tomber dans la
corruption
qui sait d'autant plus laisser tomber
dans la corruption qu'il en a oublié ses
origines
or ces origines sont divines
chrétiens nous dit qu'autrefois les
dieux se partagèrent les différentes
régions de la terre
la Grèce avait pour roi Héphaïstos et
Athéna
l'Atlantide avait pour roi Poséidon
Poséidon a eu 10 enfants avec une
mortelle
cinq fois des jumeaux
donc ils divisa l'Atlantide en 10 et
confiance chacune des 10 parties de
l'île à chacun de ces 10 fils
le premier s'appelait Atlas d'où le nom
donné à l'Atlantide
et les choses se passaient un merveille
l'île produisait tout ce qui était
nécessaire à la survie des terres
fertiles les fruits en grande quantité
des animaux de toutes sortes et même des
métaux précieux
donc très vite les Atlantes
construisirent des temples
les palais des ports
au niveau architectural les Atlantes
s'en sortent très bien
ils dirigent des constructions en pierre
et constructions dont on remarquera
d'ailleurs qu'elles sont aux couleurs
alchimiques
blanches noires et rouges
le palais royal est entouré d'une
muraille d'or et l'île dispose d'une
excellente armée
sur le plan religieux les Atlantes font
ce qu'ils ont à faire
les dieux sont vénérés des sacrifices
ont lieu et les prescriptions sont
respectées
donc on pourrait se dire tout va bien
pour les Atlantes
pas de décadence à l'horizon
non pas au début
c'est arrivé avec le temps
au début les Atlantes étaient guidées
par la vertu
par la justice par l'harmonie
et puis à partir d'un moment quelque
chose s'est produit
ils ont commencé à oublier
à oublier quoi à oublier leur origine
divine
oublier qu'ils étaient un peuple noble
un peuple sage
un peuple qui ne s'intéresse pas aux
objets de tentation
aux richesses au plaisir aux excès
voyez qu'on revient sur le sujet de la
mémoire
un peuple corrompu est un peuple qui a
perdu la mémoire
la mémoire de l'origine
une autre manière de dire que la cause
de la dégénérescence s’élurance
donc plus le temps passé plus les
Atlantes s'éloigner de leur essence
divine
c'est à dire de leur pureté originelle
et le reste indique que la cause
principale de leur corruption c'était le
métissage avec les humains
alors il faut pas y voir du racisme
plutôt du spécisme
l'espèce humaine est considérée comme
moins pure que l'espèce divine
ça peut se comprendre
nous les humains nous sommes plus
proches des animaux
nous avons des besoins physiologiques
rappelons que dans la mythologie grecque
les dieux se nourrissent d'ambroisie
c'est-à-dire d'une nourriture qui rend
immortelle
tandis que nous nous sommes mortels
du point de vue des dieux notre vie se
rapproche plus de la survie
nous sommes mortels notre corps est
mortel et c'est parce que notre corps
est mortel qu'il est attiré par les
plaisirs d'ici-bas
la sensualité
l'excitation la jouissance
ce qui fait précisément qu'on se sent
vivant
les dieux ne sont pas dans la jouissance
ils sont dans la neutralité
dans l'équilibre
l'être humain l'incarne pas l'équilibre
il incarne le négatif
le négatif c'est à dire le besoin
le désir
le manque
donc les Atlantes qui étaient très
vertueux au départ comment ce petit à
petit a dégénéré car obligé de se
reproduire avec des êtres humains
et là il commença à agir à l'encontre
des principes divins
ils apprennent à devenir ambitieux
orgueilleux envieux
il confondent le bonheur avec le plaisir
jusqu'au moment où il déclare la guerre
à Athènes
une guerre qui perdront avant que l'île
ne soit englouti
alors là il y a un vrai questionnement à
avoir sur le fait que l'engloutissement
de l'Atlantide serait à la fois dû un
cataclysme naturel et un châtiment divin
parce que ça c'est bizarre
pourquoi c'est bizarre
parce que le prêtre égyptien a dit que
les cataclysmes étaient réguliers
il parle d'un intervalle de temps
ordinaire
comme si finalement les cataclysmes
faisaient partie des cycles naturels
comme si la grande conflagration
cosmique était prévue dans les lois
astronomiques elles-mêmes
et d'ailleurs dans le 6 mai Platon parle
d'un cycle cosmique qu'il appelle la
grande année
et qu'il évalue à 25920 ans
il l'appelle la grande année parce que
c'est le temps que met une constellation
pour faire un tour complet sur elle-même
cette grande année est divisée en 12
mois chaque mois durant 2160 ans et
c'est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les
zodiacs
un zodiaque c'est un moi cosmique
et donc l'idée qui va avec ça c'est qu'à
la fin d'un cycle on a droit à un
cataclysme
un déluge ou un holocauste
je rappelle kolokoste ça veut dire
sacrifice par le feu
les chrétiens l'ont appelé apocalypse
qui signifie en même temps révélation
donc si on prend en compte tous ces
éléments on a l'idée que la disparition
de l'Atlantide serait dû un cataclysme
s'inscrivant dans un cycle cosmique et
que ce cycle cosmique correspond en même
temps ainsi que de décadence à l'issue
duquel la civilisation mérite d'être
détruite
et si c'est bien ça qu'il faut
comprendre alors c'est très intéressant
c'est très intéressant parce que ça
voudrait dire que le macrocosme et le
microcosme sont reliés
qu'ils évoluent en parallèle
allons même plus loin que la dégradation
morale est une conséquence du mouvement
cosmique
que la dégradation morale et le
mouvement cosmique c'est la même chose
et que plus le mouvement cosmique fait
s'éloigner les constellations de leur
point alpha plus le cœur des hommes
s'éloigne lui aussi de son point alpha
c'est-à-dire de son origine
de son origine divine
en langage non religieux on dirait de
son origine principielle
donc la décadence c'est tout simplement
l'éloignement du principe
et plus on s'éloigne du principe plus la
civilisation se matérialise
c'est à dire plus elle se soumet à la
logique du corps et oublie la logique de
l'esprit
l'esprit qui est le domaine des dieux
l'esprit disait Platon c'est la parcelle
divine en l'homme
donc au fil du temps la parcelle divine
commence à s'éteindre
on tombe dans la dégénérescence
et ce n'est qu'au terme du cycle de la
dégénérescence que la terre sera
purifiée par le feu ou par l'eau
alors la question qui se pose
obligatoirement c'est est-ce qu'on peut
éviter de tomber dans la dégénérescence
est-ce qu'on peut peut-être pas annuler
le cycle mais au moins faire en sorte
qu'on reste proche des principes pendant
la durée d'un cycle
bien simple c'est le troisième point
qu'on peut retenir du récit de
l'Atlantide à savoir la société
harmonieuse
Platon a écrit un texte qui s'appelle la
République dans lequel il explique
premièrement que la quête de l'homme
c'est le bonheur
et deuxièmement que le bonheur découle
d'une société harmonieuse
qu'est-ce qu'une société harmonieuse
une société harmonieuse c'est une
société
organisée selon les principes universels
et les principes universels ce sont les
principes qu'on peut déduire des lois
universelles
je parle ici des lois physiques des lois
astronomiques
et même des mathématiques
surtout des mathématiques
chez Platon comme chez Pythagore avant
lui l'univers est organisé par les
nombres
un nombre ce n'est pas seulement une
abstraction
c'est une réalité cosmique
une réalité invisible mais une réalité
qui se manifeste dans des phénomènes
visibles
les cycles
donc ce que dit Platon c'est que la
société doit être organisée conformément
au principe qui régissent l'univers
toujours selon l'idée que les principes
garantissent l'équilibre
or il y a une théorie sur laquelle
Platon va s'appuyer pour expliquer
comment la société devrait être
organisée
cette théorie c'est la théorie des
quatre éléments
la théorie des quatre éléments a été
énoncée pour la première fois par ANPE
au 5e siècle avant Jésus-Christ
est-ce que nous dit en pédocle c'est que
ces quatre éléments sont à l'origine de
tout ce qui existe dans l'univers
ces quatre éléments vous les connaissez
la terre l'eau l'air et le feu
donc selon pédocle la matière qui
compose l'univers serait un mélange de
ces quatre éléments
mais vous allez me dire quel rapport
avec l'organisation de la société
bien j'y viens
chaque élément est associé à une classe
sociale
l'élémentaire correspond à la classe des
producteurs
pourquoi des producteurs
parce que les producteurs
assurent la satisfaction des besoins
matériels
donc des besoins terrestres
les laboureurs ce sont ceux qui
travaillent la terre
et de la terre provient la nourriture
donc les besoins du corps
de plus l'élémentaire renvoie aux
tempéraments des producteurs
la dureté la rudesse la résistance
donc il y a un lien analogique entre
l'élémentaire et la classe des
producteurs
l'élément o correspond à la classe des
guerriers
pourquoi des guerriers parce que l'eau
représente la fluidité la mobilité
l'adaptabilité
l'eau c'est ce qui s'insinue dans les
moindres recoins
c'est ce qui se répand sur toute la
surface
quand on dit qu'une armée fonce sur
l'ennemi fondre cette image de la
liquéfaction
l'Image de quelque chose qui affluent
et quand une armée envahit un territoire
c'est un raz-de-marée
donc l'élément o c'est la classe des
guerriers
l'élément R
un élément r c'est la classe des
intellectuels
parce que l'air c'est la pensée
l'air s'évaporer
dans l'Antiquité les ailes figurer
l'esprit
parce que l'esprit permet l'élévation
vis-à-vis de la matière
avec cette idée d'altitude de hauteur
comme quand on dit que par la pensée on
prend de la hauteur sur les choses
Platon par le bien du ciel des idées
l'intellectuel c'est celui qui évolue
dans la sphère des idées
et enfin l'élément feu
et bien l'élément Feu c'est l'élément
supérieur
l'élément des rois
chez Platon la cité doit être gouvernée
par des philosophes
c'est à dire par des personnes qui
possèdent la sagesse et la vertu
qui possède le sens de la justice
or chez Platon la justice c'est la vertu
cardinale
celle dont découle toutes les autres
vertus
et d'ailleurs vous aurez remarqué que le
roi est souvent associé à la figure du
feu
comme ce fut le cas en France avec Louis
XIV le Roi Soleil
donc on a ici une stratification sociale
qui reprend analogiquement la
stratification naturelle
avec une idée de hiérarchie
l'élémentaire c'est l'élément le plus
bas parce que c'est l'élément le plus
lourd le plus pesant
donc c'est ce qui tend naturellement
vers le bas
le symbole de l'élémentaire c'est un
triangle pointe en bas
l'eau c'est un élément qui tend aussi
vers le bas mais qui en raison de sa
nature fluide a une tendance à la
dispersion
à l'éparpillement
comme on l'a dit l'eau se répand
elle prend la forme de son contenant
le symbole de l'élément o c'est un
triangle pointe en bas barré
l'air c'est un élément flottant c'est un
élément qui est au-dessus de ce qui est
au sol la terre et l'eau et qui pour
ainsi dire les enveloppes
comme la pensée enveloppe la matière
elle englobe
gonfler un ballon à l'hélium le ballon
pourra tout aussi bien aller vers le sol
que monter dans les airs
le symbole de l'élément r C'est un
triangle pointant
et enfin l'élément feu
le feu c'est ce qui tend naturellement
vers le haut
une flamme ça monte
c'est curieux quand on y réfléchit un
élément qui se propage vers le haut
le feu c'est l'Ascension
c'est la transcendance
et c'est la vie
le symbole de l'élément Feu c'est un
triangle pointe en haut
il se trouve que dans la composition de
la terre la hiérarchie des éléments est
respectée
si on prend la superficie des continents
sur Terre on s'aperçoit que c'est
environ 30%
. alors que 70% de la surface terrestre
c'est de l'eau
les mers et les océans
donc on a bien la terre d'abord et
ensuite l'eau
c'est ce qui enveloppe à la fois la
terre et l'eau
l'air c'est l'atmosphère
Atmos ça veut dire vapeur
l'atmosphère c'est donc littéralement la
sphère de vapeur
la vapeur qui entoure la terre
donc la terre l'eau l'air et le feu le
feu c'est le soleil
le soleil qui non seulement se situe
au-dessus des autres éléments le soleil
est au-dessus de l'atmosphère mais qui
en plus est une dimension très largement
supérieure à la terre
le diamètre du soleil c'est 109 fois le
diamètre de la Terre
donc on a bien terre o r f
et on peut même aller plus loin au sein
du vivant on retrouve aussi la
hiérarchie des éléments
l'élémentaire c'est le minéral
l'élément o c'est le végétal
la plante se nourrit d'eau
l'élément r c'est l'animal
animaux
c'est le souffle
la respiration
et enfin l'élément Feu c'est le divin
le divin dont on disait tout à l'heure
que l'être humain en est une parcelle
donc vous voyez que derrière cette
théorie qui peut sembler un peu vaseuse
au premier abord on a quand même une
symbolique qui se dessine
et une organisation
et bien cet organisation cette
hiérarchie cosmique
Platon nous dit qu'elle doit être
transposée dans la société
la société doit être le reflet des
principes universels
selon l'idée que le microcosme doit être
à l'image du macrocosme
pour maintenir l'équilibre
et c'est là qu'on comprendra mieux la
conception qu'avait Platon de l'âme
humaine
car pour Platon l'âme c'est le
microcosme dans le microcosme
c'est le reflet miniaturisé de l'ordre
universel
pour Platon l'âme se décompose en trois
parties
et comme vous le devinez chacune de ces
parties correspond à un élément et par
extension à une classe sociale
la partie inférieure de l'âme c'est ce
que Platon appelle l'épitoumira
c'est la partie de l'âme qui correspond
aux besoins physiologiques
au besoin du corps
le ventre et le bas-ventre
c'est donc la partie de l'âme qui
correspond à la classe des producteurs
les pitoumiant c'est à la fois le besoin
de se nourrir et le désir sexuel
la nourriture étant la condition de la
survie individuelle et le désir sexuel
la condition de la survie collective
avoir des enfants pour perpétuer
l'espèce
l’épitoumiens c'est l'élément terre
la partie intermédiaire de l'âme c'est
le tumos
le tumos c'est le courage
c'est l'ardeur
c'est la partie de l'âme qui correspond
à la classe des guerriers
si l'épitoumia correspond au ventre le
tumos correspond au cœur
d'ailleurs cœur et courage c'est la même
étymologie
donc le guerrier c'est celui qui a du
cœur
qui a du cœur parce qu'il protège la
cité et qui a du cœur parce qu'il a du
courage
on n'est plus dans la sphère du corps de
la matière
on est dans la sphère du sentiment
le tumos c'est l'élément
la partie supérieure de l'âme c'est le
Logos
le logos qui a donné logique
le Logos c'est la partie intellectuelle
de l'âme
celle par laquelle on est en contact
avec le monde des idées
c'est la tête
c'est donc la partie de l'âme qui doit
avoir l'ascendant sur les autres
celle qui doit commander
Kaput c'est la tête qui a donné décapité
et qui a donné aussi capitaine
celui qui commande
dans le Phèdre Platon utilise la
métaphore de l'attelage de chevaux il
explique que l'épitoumien et le tumos
sont semblables à deux chevaux et que le
Logos c'est le conducteur de la classe
la raison doit maîtriser les passions
le Logos c'est l'élément R
alors il manque un élément
l'élément feu
l'élément Feu c'est l'harmonie des trois
parties
c'est l'unité des trois parties
c'est l'équilibre entre les désirs la
volonté et la raison
cette équilibre qu'on retrouve dans
l'organisation cosmique
et c'est ce qui fait que chez les
anciens on accordait beaucoup
d'importance à la notion d'harmonie
parce que l'harmonie c'est à la fois
l'ordre et la beauté
la beauté comme reflet de l'ordre
harmonie ça veut dire ajustement entre
les parties
ça veut dire unité
et d'ailleurs le mot cosmos signifie
étymologiquement ordre
l'ordre c'est l'unité du multiple
et pour Platon la cité doit tendre vers
cette unité
on dit à tort que dans la République
Platon décrit la cité idéale
c'est pas la cité idéale
c'est la belle cité
Calipolis
belle parce qu'harmonieuse
harmonieuse parce qu'ordonnées
parce que juste
chez Platon le vrai le bon et le beau se
confondent dans l'harmonie
et les hommes seront d'autant plus juste
et vertueux que la société dans laquelle
ils vivent sera elle-même jusque
vertueuse
l'univers la société et l'âme sont les
trois localités de l'harmonie cosmique
et de leur ajustement dépend l'équilibre
du monde
donc tels sont les trois choses à
retenir du récit de l'Atlantide
la mémoire la dégénérescence et
l'harmonie universelle
les Atlantes ont oublié l'ordre cosmique
en oubliant l'ordre cosmique leur
civilisation a perdu son harmonie
elle est tombée dans la décadence
dans le déséquilibre
et se déséquilibre lui a été fatal
quand l'équilibre n'est plus respecté la
sanction c'est l'anéantissement
je cite
telle était la formidable puissance qui
existait alors en cette contrée et que
le Dieu assembla et tourna contre notre
pays pour la raison que voici pendant de
nombreuses générations tant que la
nature du dieu se fit sentir
suffisamment en eux ils obéiront aux
lois et restèrent attaché au principe
divin auquel ils étaient apparentés il
n'avait que des pensées vraies et
grandes en tout point et se comportait
avec douceur et sagesse en face de tous
les hasards de la vie et à l'égard les
uns des autres aussi n'ayant d’attention
qu'à la vertu faisait-il peu de cas de
leur bien et supportaient-ils aisément
le fardeau qui était pour eux la masse
de leur or et de leurs autres
possessions il n’était pas enivré par
les plaisirs de la richesse et toujours
mettre de même il ne s'écartait pas de
leurs devoirs tempérant comme ils
étaient ils voyaient nettement que tous
ces biens s'accroissaient par
l'affection mutuelle unie à la vertu et
que si on s'y attache et les honores il
périsse eux-mêmes et la vertu avec eux
tant qu'il résonnèrent ainsi et
gardèrent leur nature divine ils virent
croître tous les bien
on ne saura jamais ce que Dieu ça dit au
Dieu
mais on peut émettre des hypothèses
l'hypothèse qui vient immédiatement à
l'esprit c'est que face au constat de la
dégénérescence des Atlantes
les dieux ont pris la décision
d'anéantir l'Atlantide
remettre de l'équilibre dans le monde en
supprimant une cause de déséquilibre
dans notre esprit
exterminer une civilisation
ça nous paraît assez peu compatible avec
des dieux incarnant l'équilibre
parce que pour nous l'équilibre des
dieux ce serait une sorte de
bienveillance teintée de paternalisme
et ça c'est une vision naïve de
l'équilibre
une vision humaine de l'équilibre
à l'échelle cosmique l'équilibre ça
passe aussi par le sacrifice
le sacrifice de ce qui compromet
l'équilibre
le cosmos et pragmatique
les catastrophes font partie de l'ordre
naturel
les intempéries les maladies les virus
et nous aussi nous faisons partie de
l'ordre naturel
mais il se peut que si nous créons trop
de déséquilibres si nous perturbons un
peu trop l'ordre naturel dont nous
faisons partie
la sanction soit redoutable
et si ce jour arrive il ne faudra pas
s'en prendre au Dieu
il ne faudra s'en prendre qu'à nous-même
de ne pas avoir su maintenir l'harmonie
et pour ceux qui survivront
en tirer les enseignements et les
transmettre
car l'homme ne transmet pas seulement la
vie
il transmet également la conscience de
sa valeur
et les moyens de la protéger
je vous remercie
[Musique]